now the the dolphins weren't content to
just do one trade
they shook things up not long after the
first trade was announced by doing a
deal with the eagles
to go from 12
back to six and the eagles get the 12th
overall pick
and a first round pick in 2022 from the
dolphins who have
a lot of them so i don't know what the
dolphins are thinking at six but you
know what hey if it's all three
quarterbacks going one two three
jaguars jets 49ers you basically have
the third overall pick again if you
weren't going to take a quarterback see
this tells me the dolphins have decided
either they're not taking a quarterback
at all and they're sticking with tua or
or the guy they really like
they think is still going to be there at
six if they decide to go quarterback
i'm gonna lean more towards saying that
the dolphins are sticking with tua
for now and they're going to try to
build around them and see what they can
do miles
i i would agree with you on that and and
really it's because there
could be a run of four quarterbacks to
start off the draft
so you don't necessarily know who that
fourth quarterback is going to be
whether
the falcons decide to take that player
or they decide to trade back
for another team to another team that
would want that player who's still there
at number four and then
you could you know you pick whoever else
is there but no matter what i think that
the dolphins are gonna get a really high
quality player
at number six overall because you think
about it even if
those it's only the top three that are
quarterbacks you're still got you know
penne sewell
jamar chase kyle pitts devonta smith
jaylen waddle all of those guys
i mean that's that's five names right
there that are really high quality
players
that really i think could be top five
picks in any other situation if you
didn't have so many quarterback needy
teams
you could get one of those guys and i
think any one of those guys
would make the dolphins a much better
team especially if you're talking about
somebody like kyle
like pitts you know sewell i mean you've
got a tackle that's gonna be great i
mean he's just been so so good
there for oregon chase a really good
number one wide receiver all of those
guys i think could really help miami so
i think they're in a great spot
yeah i think that's the bottom line if
they're not going quarterback they're
still going to get a great player and
we're at the point where we're close
enough
to the draft that teams have made their
evaluations they've made up their minds
they've had access via zoom to talk to
these guys
multiple times pro days have happened
the film has been studied
coaches have been able to get involved
and chime in
with their viewpoints it's been months
for some of these coaches so
i think this is all uh the time
for these kinds of moves i'm still
fascinated by why the eagles
would slide back from 6 to 12 now
because you could sit in that spot and
wait
you don't have to make that trade now
unless they're thinking
the dolphins well the dolphins had to
have made it clear
it's now or never and the eagles the
eagles bit
but you know if it's not the dolphins
you could sell that pick to somebody
else based upon what's there at number
six i'm surprised
the eagles did it unless unless this is
their way of
eliminating the temptation of taking a
quarterback at number six if three go
in the first three picks no qb at four
no qb at five
if we're not there at six we can't take
a quarterback and we don't have to worry
about
disrupting what we already have i'm just
surprised
because i thought maybe they could get
more if they waited until that pick was
on the clock miles
perhaps but i think guaranteeing
yourself that you're going to get
another number one or a number first
round pick i should say
in the 2022 draft i i think that that's
maybe worth doing at this point
especially from miami look
if you think that miami's maybe not
gonna be as good
as they think that they're going to be
next year then that might be why you do
this
because at a certain point it's going to
mean that your draft pick next year
is a little bit higher than some of
these other picks that might be coming
in for you so
i understand it from that perspective
but also that report that we heard a few
weeks ago from chris mortensen that
they wanted to build that jeffrey lurie
i should say the owner of the team right
wanted to build around jalen hurts that
he wanted to do everything he could to
support jalen hurts
that is what this trade signals to me
that everything mortensen said in that
report is absolutely true they want to
make sure
that they can do what they can to build
around the qb and that might be why
you're eliminating the temptation
of maybe picking one six because you
think you already have one
but i think the jury's still out on
hurts we've seen that that much of him i
think he had some good moments
had some tougher moments too but for
right now it's pretty clear
they think that this is a rebuilt it's
going to be a multi-year rebuild
and they want to do it with the guy that
they already have at qb
that they took last year so i just think
that from that perspective if that's the
way you're going into it thinking
then i like this trade for the eagles
because it means that you gain
a couple of first-round picks that
you're going to need in order to build
this team
i agree and the eagles definitely are in
a spot where they have a lot of work to
do to get back to where they were just a
few
years ago hi i'm mike tarico and thanks
for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports